time why do we prefer a low body count a
woman who probably has more of a high
body count is more likely like he said
to have a child that is not aunts right
so that is all that that is that is
men's worst fear one of the men's worst
fears is a child coming into the world
and we us believing that child is ours
and it's not or or it also signifies
loyalty right like okay would you say
what do you think women fall in love
through
like how do women fall in love would you
say
do you think women fall in love through
sex come on
like do you think like the best the best
sex you've ever had
did you ever go back
um no never no
never
so I'll say why buddy what's he thinking
about it
but the point is like like the more guys
you've been with like the more like like
I don't know there's just more problems
like there's more he's more likely to
cheat so so the reason the reason you're
22 right and you want to know why body
counts so I'll give you a bit of
information and you should say
no I'm gonna give you a bit information
about bodycon I'm not asking for your
body crime I'm gonna tell you why body
count is important but you but sorry to
cut your channel but you said you don't
understand why men do you think bodycon
matters yes I think I do okay okay I
think a man shouldn't really care too
much about a woman's body because no
because nine times out of ten your body
count is higher than hers anyways so
like why'd you care okay so let me no
that's not true so let's so let me
explain it right
in order for me to get sex in order for
um Sarah to get sex we need to have some
type of value about us we need to be
able to have something presented let's
just walk out on the street baby I'm not
like you man
so that includes having
um Finance being good looking being six
foot being basically having uh six Deuce
baby basically having all the things
that women find attractive right in
order for us to sleep with high quality
women or any women in natural fact
um in order for you three women here to
sleep with with a man all you have to do
is basically say I want to sleep with
you and there'll be men that will want
to sleep with you so in order for you to
sleep with 100 100 men and and meet
asleep with 100 women is completely
different you could literally do this
and this is why a lot of times women
think that men are having so much sex
because they equate it to what they can
get but that's not the truth of the
matter the truth of the matter is I'm
gonna have to take a girl out I'm gonna
have to three dates I'm about to do all
these types of things in order to have
sex but all you have to do is say I want
to have sex and the man will have sex
and that wait so I think can I just say
right like there's two women here right
yeah that are in um I'm gonna use this
as an England energy there's two women
here and you got hoodies on right
women can walk out on the street you
women can walk out the sheet and just
hoodies and even your Bonnet right and
you can still go and you can still
Garner attention from him men will still
be like yo no it's actually shocking
it's actually shocking but the thing is
men don't get that they don't get
afforded if a man walks out looking
quote unquote bummy no one don't give a
damn do you get what I'm saying but
women can women can be mothers of five
children and go on a school run right in
their in their pajamas and men will
still holler yeah
men do not get afforded that same thing
one in three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year yeah so
it's not the most men aren't really
getting laid like that I think that it
goes back to what we were saying earlier
about what we see until we get told
these things that you know body count I
think when more people accept that men
and women are differently we all just we
argument we built differently
genetically the way you guys just get up
and kind of put it in anywhere we know
as women
you know okay no way you know what I'm
saying it's easy to just do to do that
as a woman if you're doing that like
that you kind of have to look at you
sideways because it's a different
experience for us so that we experience
it's different and I think for ages I
used to get all funny about the body
count thing because I think oh yes nasty
to do that but not saying that would be
if somebody has has a million bodies
what do you mean it's not nasty I don't
know what the man said no yeah I'm
saying I used to be like oh man's got
too many bodies yeah but now I know how
men I have three brothers yeah so the
way men operate is different as a woman
when you're accepting of that you see
things differently what do you want to
say to you women don't want a man
without sexual experience that's the
only thing that's the thing
exactly what I'm saying so the fact that
I would so the fact that right but the
thing is that's the difference between
men and women yeah that's it well yeah
men want a woman who has a lower body
count and would prefer to teach her yeah
right what sex is women want a man to
come to them and know her body right and
a man and a man can't know your body
let's just have sexual experience see
when you come with that got three
thousand one like we're enjoying it but
we're like where did you learn that from
the end of the days you're supposed to
learn no but this is a thing
because we're enjoying it we're like
damn but we're like damn what did she
learn how many guys and then your brain
starts doing the whole thing so for us
men we don't prioritize sexual
experience as anything in actual fact
the less sexual experience you have the
better for us we don't look at we don't
look at you as sex as being something as
a selling point for women they think
they is but we don't for men you
actually look at it's like I want a man
that knows what what to do but for us we
don't actually want that so A lot of
times when we're trying to speak to
we're trying to say like whoever's told
you this it's a fallacy it's a lie like
men don't do not Pride sexual experience
when we're looking for a woman we look
at femininity we look at loyalty we look
at low body count some of these other
things
um obviously like
um family family oriented but not once
have we ever said you know what I want
to know know what I had techniques like
but there's a flip side to me go on let
me hear it we know that because the
reason why men go to strip clubs yeah
right there's a reason why men indulge
in corn right interesting to this degree
is because they fantasize about these
women that can do all of these things
right we do we fantasize about them and
I can do all of these things but then
when we go into our relationship we
don't want a woman like that because
that's going to be our wife but there's
that
there's that okay if a woman can show
you sex experience and she can show you
all of these things we get turned on
this turned on by it so there is
literally there's a there's a bit of a
dichotomy there with men and I think I I
think a lot of women struggle to
understand that so we understand it as
men no I fully like like I fully hear
what you're saying and you're right and
I've heard women say oh but why'd you
guys like this like all these girls
pictures on Instagram yeah yeah you're
looking at you're looking at one night
versus a lifetime exactly so if you want
to be the girl for what there's so many
girls like the girl for one night you
know like they don't get the ring they
don't get the life they don't get none
of these things they just get the one
night they get the they get the
champagne bottles they get the sparklers
they get their back blown out and that's
it they might even get a bag from one of
these guys they don't get anything other
than that and at some point even those
girls want something more you know what
I'm trying to say to you so I think a
lot of the times it's just looking at
things from a different from a different
angle and that's why I agree with you a
lot but men we just want these things
for now not for a lifetime and you what
would you rather be a girl for now or go
for the lifetime so I've always said to
women like do you think that you can
differentiate
attention from men like do you
understand when a guy is looking at you
and is giving you attention because he
wants to [ __ ] you basically or can you
differentiate it when a guy wants to
actually make you his long-term partner
that I think a lot of women say I think
a lot but I think a lot of women
struggle with that like they struggle
with differentiating between that type
of attention especially depend on the
setting and stuff as well yeah
and yeah I know that I agree and so what
happens is because it is a tension and
women lack attention they think a lot of
the guys that are trying to pursue them
which is why a lot of women think oh I
can back this type of guy because blah
blah blah no he will show you attention
because he wants to [ __ ] you but he's
not showing you the attention because he
wants to be of you long term and so a
lot of women have had attention from
guys who are of that top percentage
and they think oh I can bag me that guy
it's like no but he will [ __ ] you
and that is a hard pill to swallow for a
lot of women they don't get that they're
the woman that guys just want to [ __ ]
and they don't want to have a long-term
relationship with
do you know what I mean like there's a
lot of people there's someone for
everyone what there's someone for
everyone how how when women make up 55
of the population and there's more of
Austin yeah but yeah I genuinely think
someone's got to be the hookers
someone's gotta do I share numbers this
is the world's oldest profession
someone's gotta do it well by [ __ ] I
never want someone I love to do it but
but someone will and someone's got it
but what you say this by sheer numbers
someone's gonna have to share a man yeah
because just if you paid everybody up
one one with each other there's gonna be
how many millions of women on the
sideline like yo but what about me a
certain question for the ladies you you
have a guy six feet six figures six
inches or would you share him pay what
more than six inches
if it was like oh two as long as I'm
honest like living in the Mansion yeah
you know got the kids driving the
Bentley yeah I feel like See No Evil
Hear No Evil yeah I don't yeah
this phone ring at 2AM
most people are actually doing that now
anyways it's not it's nothing new yeah
so then that goes back to the
traditional relationship are they dead
so you're saying as a woman you'd be
you'll be like okay oh cool I can share
it man that's not a traditional
relationship no but I would argue that
probably yeah way back yeah I would
argue three ways yeah I would argue like
sorry but it is a little bit even if
they didn't like what Pearl used to say
like they had you know they had a whole
[ __ ] as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible